[Music]
level dama Reville Reville Reville
[Music]
well
or
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
the
this episode of the handsome Rambler is
brought to you by bevel it's the first
and only shave system designed for
coarse curly hair and sensitive skin so
step up your shaving game and save by
going to get bevel calm slash Hannibal
and get rid of those razor bumps live
good with bevel feel nice get that full
shape system and a nice trimmer I mean
you're hearing this from a guy named
Tony trim so you could trust in me so
check them all to get double comm slash
Hannibal let's get GG etbe ve Elcom
slash Hannibal naturebox s sponsor in
the podcast naturebox
thank you for your money nature box has
so many snacks and they're good for you
they got so many my favorites are
sunflower seeds and something else is
something else a great variety of snacks
of great snacks who doesn't like snacks
you don't like snacks you're a real
piece of [ __ ] what happened to you as a
kid right now naturebox is offering
handsome rambling fan 3 free snacks with
your first order when you go to nature
box.com slash Rambler that's how
confident they are they gonna give it
out for free cuz you gonna come back
that's naturebox.com/tyler for three
free snacks naturebox.com/tyler
m-move first an amount freestyle feels
off to fill up yo Wow
oh my gosh
look you know that my gosh get Janelle
this book movies cliff good news
roasting my my my gosh it now this Rufus
whoa
[Music]
yeah man shut the mouth of Aaron what
collective molted sir yeah but I read
dr. animal I tried to fit it in outside
the bar in yeah I feel like my yeah my
freestyle a little bit little bit off
you're not feeling the flow today
sometimes you just don't got it exercise
you know sometimes you gotta exercise
you don't you don't got it in one of
them days yeah it's another special
episode we did some live interviews at
mold fest
first one is with your favorite band
Animal Collective huh that's your
favorite band one of my favorite one of
your face often Leon my top ten top ten
dead or alive dead or alive Animal
Collective love them nirvana
mmm diggable planets mm-hmm fish mm-hmm
no our noble fish gets a fish out of
there
afro red and the roots that the roots
should be keep the roots kid get the
Afro man out of there uh just Jimmy
required his bed a stale you know uh
Sergio Mendes uh
Santana we are these your favorite bands
with my favorite guest anyways yeah
listen to this quick talk with Animal
Collective in John Mills cockle great
despite that very fun intro is wrong
guess what the Flying Lotus interview is
first animist Animal Collective one
after that life is full of twists and
turns
check out Flying Lotus his new movie
kuso set me out of FYF fest in Los
Angeles July
920 first Friday and thanks for
listening and check out my tour dates
Hannibal Burres dot-com boom later music
[Music]
alright alright bye bye
my co-host Tony trim give us eyes
through thank you all a lot we excited
depierre most this is one weird fest
we're running on a high clock so without
further ado please welcome fly Lotus
pile over here
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we give against it so we improvise
intro music slam Lotus press off the
plane you put out flat oh look I don't
want to talk just on make music what if
they get on the light he sitting on of
mine what if he what of first levels I
don't want to say anything to you guys
I'm just gonna [ __ ] around over here you
talk about whatever you want to talk
about I'll call it there I was ready in
the zone man eligible choco banana top
of line let alone as we just commentate
a while that's a Model T right there
flylo's [ __ ] away
okay yeah oh that was great in so my
cool release yeah that's not that's not
how credit credit guitar II hooked it up
so organelle and [ __ ] as dope as [ __ ]
you say critter critters ain't guitars
if the name yeah a school accompany
what's that man you just get and you
just landed like 30 minutes ago yeah
what the [ __ ] you got me doing where am
i feel like i don't do a podcast with me
i like why are we at a video why are we
in the green room why I'm on the stage
and tell the people about them is here
and y'all producers all y'all producers
out there
oh [ __ ] a lot of beef yeah no [ __ ] I'm
like 20,000 beats out there for louder
yeah that's a lot of SoundCloud pages
it's a lot a lot of peeps out there yeah
pull out a Dropbox account maybe even
pro yeah how many Dropbox programs you
get out there
prowling yes yeah but not if you if you
would you like Google Drive more than
make some noise oh [ __ ] with google
translator Iron Man somebody tell me
something on Google Drive maybe like did
you get that but yeah I saw it right
away but couldn't do it
I want to work with you I'm not flaky
but that Google Drive Satar me into an
old man yeah that's the most I relate to
my dad is when somebody sends me music
or files on Google Drive a little call
my nephew as real sit you put out a few
new songs this week man I did yeah you
put out some captain Murphy yeah captain
Murphy songs
hey captain Murphy you are OC got all
the toys up here when you when you're
rapping as captain Murphy is it just you
in the session
doing the doing a recording yes it's me
usually I don't like doing then try
anybody yeah yeah because you know I
start off just like gibberish at first
when others it might depend and then the
gibberish is like oh well that's
actually you know pocket and then it
turns into words and then record it so
it's real personal all right find it you
know yeah do you still say even though
it's just you by yourself do you still
say take over after studios turning [ __ ]
up no put the headphones a little bit so
where's my snare and uh
you released some new music under it was
a crazy song under a group is that blue
tight under death Lotus son to death
Lotus is that Thundercat Thundercat
Brendon small from Dethklok
Metalocalypse and myself oh [ __ ]
I'm just hearing a lot of his mouth
that's awesome yeah we did a couple
tracks we did a couple tracks when I was
working on the year Dead album I was
doing a lot of like crazy metal inspired
stuff and you know I hit up Brendan
because of Al venue the metal master
yeah we just we just linked up and you
know got to it but the tracks never came
out and it didn't really fit for your
dead so I just allow SoundCloud four
years later this is a senior metal fan
yeah it phases you know phases I like
Gojira and you know Mastodon yeah I love
that [ __ ] of course gods be I don't know
that counts well by God to be a lot you
know like that they know I'm happy I'm
not being rude I'm just pulling up tooth
on the devil Otis track oh yeah where's
my aux cord
what
[Music]
[Applause]
you are y'all hit it oh never mind I
give up bucket yeah just go on
Soundcloud at some point yeah sound file
and don't click on your page you click
on mine you know just yeah don't click
on your own without you don't click on
your own songs to get your views up some
of you do that you know I got to make it
up this week yo so uh you mute your
movie kusu-kusu which I have voice a a
character in yeah you did
that's gross man so gross movie I was
like there is an extreme like oh you
know what I like you know what this is I
don't know if he said this weird man I
like Hannibal Hamels like surprised I'm
making a weird movie we having a problem
ah it was it was it was pretty crazy he
said it like three times yeah I was like
weird man my cousin says here's the
vocals but Godspeed Godspeed whatever
you do with it but you guys got
distribution yeah got distribution movie
comes out this summer hopefully into
July in theaters some something um
theaters yet and I transformers but you
know we get some theaters yeah
I want to see it I want to see it as a
package every female movie well no yes
any tube you know like I don't want to
watch I don't want to watch this by
myself I need some people around me
that's the case I'll break down that's
the best that's the best way to watch it
watch it with somebody you don't like
we're yeah that's the way to do it so
you uh you working on any other movie
stuff yeah I'm writing the next one
it's called Sode Sode yeah can I pitch
myself to to be on a soundtrack
that's the openness thing suck sure that
works fade in
what's the sign about I can't tell you
okay I can't tell them I'll tell you
later look in a world of Secrets yes in
a world of Secrets I
this is a move on acid right now cuz uh
probably really weird for you for y'all
that's people dollars I think the last
time I saw you we did acid together
oh yeah that was amazing
he's such a G for that he's such a G
like I invited him over the crib early
in the morning hanging out took a bunch
of acid what totally forgot he was
coming over Oh
shows up at my door like oh man I'm
tripping right now why instantly is like
you got any more that dirty water yeah
join me you proceeded to make 20 beats
in 20 minutes how do you mean like it
was a light amount and white is called
micro doses it was a micro doses in the
end and I made some beats and uh you
know how they turn out
he created his other than money it was
yeah awesome piece here let me
oh yeah yeah yeah and I thought I was a
chosen one was like a lot of a hip-hop
fan but apparently I'm only capable of
creating just goth rock recorder you're
a few much okay I guess that's how I am
warmer you are and yeah thank you a
filler in a yes but in real life you
guys Rock yeah [ __ ] Marilyn Manson
side-project you got to be yourself
around your peers I was definitely
impressed with like the first two yeah
it was good yeah and then acid wore off
and I send the rel after midnight I
can't make beats any Molly but you've
been to both of us before I think this
is my third yeah in a row three times on
a rope not a rope oh I missed it last
year yeah
which one is that one goddamn [ __ ] come
on down this was second year this is
been in on dawn and I wonder who's
anybody would ask real last names like
only a few hours away I'm good four
hours away that's well I was that you
know I was there yeah that's a long ride
away that's that's a long place to just
replace the festival idea do you have to
send it home this one now I have a
Voyager as a collegiate I gotta voyage
it too so we had asked yeah what do you
usually use it for baseline faithful me
- yeah yeah I can't wait until they make
that polyphonic mode
there are polyphonic mogh more than one
note I'm sorry
yes coffee I am it's an expensive ass no
more than one note I want to play a
chord for [ __ ] two three thousand
dollars they know they know that Oh new
information let's buddy what uh it's
used a polyphonic no de mano mano yeah
yeah that's what we're living did you
use that did you use that on [ __ ]
dead my favorite song no nothing outside
it's all good
I used it a lot on the Los Angeles album
I use the Voyager I love it on that yeah
you know I when I'm ever using this to
the Pandora I had a Pandora station of
yours and this [ __ ] comes up on yours
too having hurt and a lot of the artists
one track that came up was a kill your
co-workers yeah
vintage that [ __ ] is like morning music
man yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's a good
tractus ship clothes have you done many
Kip tools tracks there was a there was a
era of that where I was really going in
on you know the 8-bit sound you know
that but I don't really been doing that
lately yeah right now I've been working
on a lot of
[ __ ] I shouldn't say listen I tell
people because you already told me that
you get into salsa music yeah I think
the people most want to hear that how to
say others have been doing a bunch of
Vangelis inspired stuff for a specific
project coming out wait what is what did
you just say that the whole crowd
understood but I did Vangelis been
jealous yeah was that I don't know what
that is really don't look at me Francis
why that's why you ask questions I'm not
like a fake nod or either you not gonna
you know sherry for fire no damn good
[Music]
okay okay he did that yeah he also did a
blade runner soundtrack okay okay I
haven't heard the blade on a soundtrack
I got a lot of later on dude no I
haven't seen Blade Runner or the Goonies
I have the same I haven't seen a lot of
stuff that people hold liars
you never saw Goonies I haven't seen
cool even if you ask me again my answers
to the site I have seen jaws everybody
Anatomy I have seen John Young now cause
I can forgive but not Goonies everything
jaws I haven't seen a lot of young men
will people get upset how to say any
other Harry Potter
damn it for now the people be like
although [ __ ] in winter the landlord
of the Ring
yeah
[Music]
Oh juicy would you wet fart simulator
[Music]
I like that patch yeah that's a good one
yeah it's good yeah I want to switch it
up I want to I want to do theremin for a
reality show music like this they should
mix it up with me put some theremin in
life my 600-pound life I think that's
your instrument right there no I'm not
paper in the world yeah it's my favorite
thing in the world our baby is big and
me undi the responder of mine
yes whoo yeah listen what do you uh when
you making music do you put movies on in
the studio we put on karate or people
fighting god it's just a different good
question you know it's a good question
actually
I like to put movies on sometimes but
not all the time I think it's nice to
have the ambience but I when I'm working
I just really try to stay focused like
it's like any distraction it'll just
take me away right now I've been playing
overwatch now the album is delayed
are you a daytime worker a nighttime
worker
it depends mostly daytime okay I have
most of my brain space in the morning
but a nighttime so damn [ __ ] high
like yeah as a vegetable
get up drink coffee that just goes out
to one man I just got out of coffee
recently yeah Diddy Kong city [ __ ] what
time call me dark roast basically you
get my guaranteed energy guarantee take
a [ __ ] good to go
yeah check out the man's got a point
because after you [ __ ] and got that
energy you ready to take over the world
absolutely for like 45 minutes yeah yeah
then it's back to your usual [ __ ] man
see I thought that coffee life when I
was uh I tried it when I was writing
their 30 rock just because it was a it
was a nine-to-five job and I have to be
up early and it was you know even as a
comedy driver is still a office
environment so I would try to drink
coffee to keep up but then I'll be
[ __ ] three times before noon but the
thing is
the writing office was at the end of the
production office so I had to keep on
walking past like thirty people are
crazy walk back again and I goddess
isn't worth it you know everything you
know what else will feel weird you'll
feel weird to take a [ __ ] and then come
back into the writers room and then like
have an idea like what a crazy fare like
I'll just [ __ ] but I know the goal
my ideas aren't valid for at least
another ten minutes it's like you should
be pitching stuff for yeah any winnings
they come right after you [ __ ] it is so
wrong well I got you a point good point
I think what I saw you last that uh my
house that's not a house without my
houses
oh well before that set the Thundercats
out oh yeah Emma your Liza yeah
Thundercats is killing it right now
yeah he is I'm so proud of him yeah that
is amazing that was great yeah all right
what's your favorite track Oh probably
friend zone so friend zone one okay ov
are you favorite track maybe I'm biased
but Jethro is my favorite okay I think
depending on my mood
uh-huh you see the bus in these streets
my go-to - yeah so what about it wasn't
a lot about cats
um yum yum yeah Sean sighs yeah yeah
fans mail tooth or whatever talk to ya
body of his ass lives on there meow meow
meow meow
yeah no that wasn't that was my idea and
he was like there's no hesitation when
we understand why you just meow that
part right there is that it was it has
happened and it was beautiful it was
your idea yeah
we didn't know that's it that's the
thing about cat he was just like it
there's no like processing it really it
just jumps right into it and it's like I
always I'm always fascinated by how his
mind works you know I'm like so spoiled
to get to work with him all the time
he's a man who like he's never without
an idea you know and the fact of his
mind he always has something he can say
any given moment with that base and it's
it's [ __ ] amazing to watch he's on
and I work with other musicians and I'm
just like expecting the same yeah I'm
saying and they always like that you
know but with him he's truly like a mad
genius like what do you call it like a
idiot savant is that guy eyes get
through to I mean he's so humble like
you'd never guess really maybe like two
homes ago I guess I don't want to tip 11
you guys spent a lot of time together
yeah we do yeah know each other at a
different level play I like 3:00 a.m.
3:00 a.m. on that track Hey yeah oh cool
let's go out like shorts no y'all do a
lot of uh yeah enter Louisiana Looney
songs that fall around the minute mark
is that that's not a planet exist where
you kind of know that it is a short in
people who run it back a lot yeah a lot
of times I think people overstay their
welcome yeah you know like you after I
feel like I know I was gonna go then
just cut that [ __ ] right I think you
know it but this is me this is me and I
think he likes to work in a similar way
because you know we did the drunk record
I had to go through one hundred and
some-odd track ya figure out like what
was going to be on album Wow he like
what how we work usually is he'll chip
away at stuff for a little bit and have
a bunch of demos and then he'll be like
all right
do something with this yeah all right
okay this is a mess you know but it's
always like I figure it out we all
figured out and putting it together but
uh yeah you know like that 3 a.m. song I
was that was a short and sweet kind of
moment that fit what's up mouth and you
know just fine in that and kind of you
know whatever stress that's great like
so you'll just kind of jam on has it all
day give it to you and have you cut it
up and turn it into something else like
basically like can i that help me and
that's how me and him do like ads for
our podcast right I'll just be like hit
record I'm like go crazy in there later
man weeks later it'll be like a full
like me undies ad so like kind of like
that yeah yeah I think he's the kind of
person he's just like I think he just
says to me like you know I just want to
sing and play bass I don't want to think
about anything
yeah and I try to accommodate that
you're like the technical guy that puts
it all together ya know here's what I
wonder honor numbers in just because I
know [ __ ] dead is one of those short
songs and 3 a.m. and I listen to those a
lot of those over know do you see it in
your streaming numbers we do you see
like those minute minute and a half and
hundred songs do they have more plays
than a lot of the other songs you know
I'll be honest if I got into analytics
of my own music I'll [ __ ] kill myself
probably so I really try to not get in
that you should I should too
no but I just I can't deal man yeah I
don't want to know that never catch me
as my most popular song I don't want to
know that not I'm saying I don't want to
be influenced by so I know you know
thank Kendrick you know for that but uh
you know I I just yeah that
is enough stuff going on in my head I
don't want to be thinking about that
kind of [ __ ] I want to create and do my
thing because getting to that point
takes a while yeah you know there's so
much stuff happening so it's like I just
want to like save whatever that brain
space I can you know a run label I got a
film company now so all of it is kind of
like you know so whenever I get to sit
and create I want to [ __ ] think about
analytics and who is going to and who
was made for and was honor and all that
[ __ ] you know that's yeah that's fair
and is always bothered me because back
in the days when people talk about some
music like so how many units did you
become yeah you know this what are you
talking about that yeah good yeah dreams
I think if I just knew about my music is
dreams I [ __ ] get all depressed about
it yeah yeah if it's sad it's sad you
know that streams yeah that's a bad way
to talk about it yeah and plus you know
I'm the kind of person I try to I make
records like as you know from the whole
experience I don't just do like all this
is a single chuck it in there you can go
there's like a tracklist that I
organized to be a certain way and I hear
the people are like shuffling the songs
like oh yeah no I didn't make it for
that project it's like a whole yeah yeah
you know it's just it's giving in to
that kind of thinking it kind of [ __ ]
me up a little bit but you know that's
how the world works right yeah I noticed
you set up your albums like their novels
and [ __ ] there's chapters and there's
there's obvious build climax of yeah
conclusion so when people are skipping
around I could see that that would drive
you crazy yeah absolutely does but you
know now it's a bit different now than
it was when I did the last album so you
know I have these things in mind for
this new one so we'll see what happens
yeah that is when it is a certain when
is an album that's obviously you know
sequenced and some songs might have
taken hair bleed a different part of it
was the
the Anderson pack and no worries album
that it flows the whole thing flows like
you know as one piece and so I think one
time I was playing it and that's it was
on shuffle but I didn't know it was on
shuffle so one song went to another when
the messages was about to naturally flow
it in a charge to another song yeah and
I think I'm a little bit autistic cuz I
was like wow yeah I want to saw me off
yeah like you know bucks with you for
real I'm supposed to be there that's
like put the wrong piece of the puzzle
there yeah yeah I got you so you got the
show tonight yeah have to play after
headlining have to play after DJ premier
I should just kill myself now wait
please you got you got you gonna have
one uh apples and oranges well sure I
don't have any songs with Biggie or
jay-z I could pull from so I rock the
crowd but you got flaws with Kendrick
and I are over here we should play that
like that looking to you right now we
want it what's up what's your approach
to the sort of visuals in the input do
you have a theme to that or do you
collaborate and just throw out a bunch
ideas and they kind of work with it how
does that come together the original
show that I did the layer three show was
an idea that I had and my friends we put
it together and they strange loop and
time boy they're out there yeah we put
that together and then we expanded on it
and did a hypercube but as far as all
the content goes you know there's it's
all very it comes from all around you
know some some things happen you know
some of my friends make some I made some
but we outsource a lot of animations and
stuff yes
then to show with you you taught
yourself how to animate for consult yeah
yeah how long how do you do that
[ __ ] mixing tutorial YouTube yeah hey
do you still give it to anything YouTube
again honestly I was so I was so into it
as well like first we have to be
obsessed and then you can you know how
few friends I could hit up like David's
first and you know this is business per
few guys in the circle use after sex and
you know I just exhaust the [ __ ] out of
him and went on YouTube and learned
other stuff and but yeah it was a it's
really fun to do that but you your life
just flies past you know I was working
on that a bit
and I spent like two months and my house
is like working on like seconds of
animation and the all I do I can't be
doing this [ __ ] no more as I use your
hands like this is it this is the result
of that [ __ ] movie I might cut my
hair when the movie comes out so I'll
just be like you know but maybe not when
you started doing animation was it just
like I'm going to do this just to prove
that I could do it not to make a booth
yeah it started off because I really
like this gif going around and it was
like a really silly gif of me and Tom
you're DJing at a party and I was really
hilarious and I was like I could do that
but way crazier and then I like went
into the rabbit hole and then a whole
movie happen but when I go to a rabbit
hole in Italy I know way more about you
than I'd like to
that's wherever you mean world follow a
cure for Jordan loss Thank You gravity
bah
you got to show the prep point gets me
get blended
I'll check our fly low tonight and 45
set thank you thanks a lot man we'll see
over thank you plan Lotus everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so we were one time we went to
played with we see purple flowers do you
spell here also looks like fly a lot of
times already deputies are important for
some people you know you do it wouldn't
you oh god we have a fall yeah oh yeah
comfortable I'm time to talk about
what's been going on yet why don't you
tell people what's been going on yeah
having a good time
my Animal Collective last night Animal
Collective put on a great shelf amazing
show great show good visuals yeah that's
it was great
now the craziest thing is that that does
ship wasn't like daisy chained to like
midi timing or anything they were just
doing all that [ __ ] on the floor to do
that [ __ ] line they saw i'ma cry yeah
all of them have had like their little
space don't [ __ ] up up yeah why was
fly loaded like good attention right
away he's fine yeah no I think he
actually turned it off and I think the
exciting is going on huh
okay well probably you know I think the
move is to come up with a strong clothes
and get the [ __ ] out of here okay
all right you aren't doing your animal
collective impression again that was
I kind of had that moment already oh you
know what let's do a are you doing a
present with Animal Collective and the
mEagle did a song - all right how I go
there it is
approach okay you give me some drums
give me some Eagle drums okay and I'll
I'll try to auto tune in so we'll be
block somewhere
all right okay hold up Stepanek boot
machine you know any ten minutes can you
put wiggle lemon you know what is a
great idea but it's not to pull off the
execution you're on the five pounds on
the spot my mom Yanni will probably make
a dope song together yeah because a
collab I want me goes and Animal
Collective I'm putting it out into the
universe what the wait but we didn't
talk about Animal Collective they did
the collab last night when they came out
the intro oh yeah Michael Winslow
that was crazy Michael Winslow model
Winslow y'all know Michael Ronald police
academy yes that he said to 80% confused
crowd no he had walked up into the
camera man he said something and then I
just forgot about it I was like cool
whatever and then he showed up and I was
like wait a minute
oh [ __ ] put two and two together and
then he went up on stage started doing
loop and stuff and then Animal
Collective comes out behind them and
then they all just start playing
together it was like is this really
[ __ ] happening yeah
yeah I think SPECT - yeah stayed up for
the first two songs yeah yeah and he was
like making crazy experimental noises -
and looping them like well like Alba
collective was doing their thing you had
to have been there I guess
happen in my life yeah we were there we
were there that's true yeah where the
[ __ ] else really would everybody who
wasn't that crazy that was more for the
listeners at home
black nice pub people
ah I was I have a little kid if I have
to put a kid in the back of has a kid it
I'll use it if if my parents were angry
at me watch you put that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh all right all right get mad if you
care to do it we don't get a hero
problems I need for you to solver go
engines nights away you know this I'm
the youngest and I say course upon [ __ ]
I'm fine play up and stick just show me
like all right it's all the towpath
Alturas see ya later man
Holly trim text that moped or type of
client loaders see all that Michelle
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's next that's not that's excess
that you know this episode is sponsored
by nature box nature box has health
snacks and they're good you get all
types of snacks
I like sunflower seeds and I like the
peaches and honestly I've been waiting
on my shipment because I'm traveling so
I haven't had any snacks yet but I'm
sure that the snacks are good you're
going to find a new snack obsession they
add new snacks every month yeah to go to
nature boxes I kind of pick your snacks
and if it's a snacking on like nature
box will replace it for free um and
right now you'll save more nature box is
offering handsome Rambler fans three
free snacks with your first order when
you go to naturebox.com/tyler
that's naturebox.com/tyler for three
free snacks with your first order nature
box.com slash rambling this episode of
the handsome Rambler is brought to you
by bevel the first and only shade system
designed for coarse curly hair and
sensitive skin step up your shave game
and save by going to get bevel calm
slash Hannibal sget Deezy Deezy Cellcom
slash and
get rid of those shitty razor bombs in
Richmond with bevel they've got the full
shave system in a futuristic trimmer and
you know what a futuristic trimmer
sounds like right
[Music]
check them out again
that'll calm slash Hannibal that's gdg
gdg real calm slash and
[Music]
hey milkface how's it going right hey
there we go all right hey nice to see
you guys I'm Hannibal Burres yeah
because it's news reduce ourselves Tony
trim my co-host I hope the handsome
rambling podcast uh I'm always you see
yeah somebody that's like all mushrooms
right now just freaked out weird noises
freaked you out when your mushrooms on
I'm excited because my first time at
this festival it's uh it's night you
know what I've been getting a lot of
from people hey what are you doing here
yeah I had a couple people we saw I
lived quietly
yesterday we I wasn't and we're not when
he hopped out of his van he's I Hannibal
what are you doing here
I don't know man ones that stuck with a
theremin and you know and I was on it
because when you think of somebody
perfect to interview Animal Collective
you again
Hannibal Birds right as it that's the
perfect person to interview animal
collectors like yeah oh yeah that's
happening so uh I'm excited I'm not you
know genuinely nervous because I like
the music but I you know I don't know
how to talk about it you know what I
mean we like yeah but then but then I
looked at at Twitter and insulted Trump
is still being terrible with his job and
I was like I it's not that bad yeah I
was just a closetful talking the theater
toys you playing this isn't talking a
theater yeah if he's [ __ ] up the
world and words I'm just [ __ ] up an
hour and a half
yeah and her knitting foam and it's the
mother programmer you can go see that
you know clean the taste yeah so without
further ado please welcome Animal
Collective
[Applause]
Don Mills taco some sirak sawmill toggle
Fatima clucking I was listening to you
guys a the latest album and it's
disorienting it's like good but you know
I some music is good driving music but I
feel like dry I was driving to it
nothing cool about to get a DUI this is
too crazy it's super chaotic so do you
when you're making music are you trying
to create a certain vibe while you're
trying to make you try to evoke that
type of emotional you just make it and
then see what happens I think our music
sounds way less chaotic to us than it
does to everybody else we always think
we're making like our minimal record
with not too much going on it's not the
way it goes down with the public would
know it's it's not intentional what's
the most layers a track as head of you
guys we've gone over 100 but I bet
they're home to serve vocals are all 100
always layered you are the singing so
you had 99 in one of you like indie
something innocent actually have a more
vocal line you guys he has opened for
Miles Davis indeed yeah yeah how's that
the [ __ ] brewed to her right oh man
yeah that I mean I am a huge I was I get
I am a huge Miles Davis fan and so it
was pretty mind-blowing really that you
know and but I mean it's always
disappointing with these things you know
the occasionally you'll meet you'll meet
celebrity artists Miles Davis is one of
the jazz grace of all time obviously and
you know it was the same with that we
play with the Rabi Shankar and as you
know so forth but so I go up to Myles
same thing happen with Dizzy Gillespie's
meeting with Dizzy Gillespie was tragic
right
you go up there some of them are they're
all great guys but you know they're very
very focused here's miles in Massey Hall
one of the you know the historic hall
really because Johnny Parker played
there you know maybe just famous Massey
Hall recording there and so miles we
played we played first I go up the BIOS
as was a mile I just he just don't talk
to me right now
kind of looks past me like that the
worst ones I was dizzy gillespie hi I
bet into the town countering and I go up
to him I was there with my father I was
quite young I just really wanted to say
hello to you and meet you and he was
eating right and he holds that to his
knife state and he said if you say one
more word to me I'm going to cut you
can you hear me is that I'm serious I
thought the can hear me I had a bad
celebrity encounter with former
Sacramento Kings player Peja Stojakovic
what happened I was look at the it was
all-star weekend in New York and uh it
was in between events so people kind of
just walking around yeah and I saw him
and I said what's up paisa and then he
just looked at me and then say anything
and then he just went further to go get
ignored by Ron Harper he's I Ronnie and
Ronnie didn't hear em and I like Carver
[ __ ] you got it
[ __ ] any stories like that no soy too
many people well sure why I had to
record a Jimmy Buffett concert once when
a was like a private I went to this
parrot store in Greenwich Village this
is a good one yeah we worked at a parent
wait I thought bourbon burger you know
we're like on 6th Avenue and it's
there's like I get confused me Greenwich
Street and gage Greenwich Avenue yeah
was there and one day my boss was like
it was like an open store the parents
which is out and right one day my boss
said I need you to come to this party
it's like a 40th birthday party for some
hedge-fund dude you just have to have
the two parrots on your shoulder and
like let the guessin are after them for
like a themed event which turned out to
be a private Jimmy Buffett concert Oh
cuz they met each other bidding over the
same yacht and Jimmy lost but they
became friends and he just likes parrots
that is after parties yeah if he was
addicted I mean my boss like tried to
get photos and he I think he said like
leave me alone I'm working yeah
somewhere thing Boston hoops all I got
who knows can you say that to a guy with
a parrot on your shoulder
are you Eric you're dangerous though
that you get seriously bitten by a
parrot yeah you can think live here you
have to pair it you do that in real life
no no no oh you will agree with him you
know what I've been bitten I'm a lot at
that I mean in one summer
I've still got a cigar here from a uh oh
you guys are being real yep we did this
movie called um odds backhoes like our
own movie and the house we filmed it at
had the parrot from Doctor Dolittle like
the family owned it yeah I got bit by
that pirate after it bit her to just mix
that they're loyal to their owners and
I've never owned one
I'm very territorial is a statue well
what is the parrot market right now hi
he's happy buddy what did I go for is it
like $750 or what are you know they're
supposed in my day one got stolen
because we used to just let them out and
somebody took one one time and put him
in a jacket and like ran and I remember
my boss giving us like a lecture being
like that was six hundred and fifty
dollars yeah I walk out the door
hey did I send you pictures I was at
this random burn shop one day it was
across the street waiver to sit down it
there was a burn shop and there was like
his rare like it was a macaw and the
thing was like seven grand
yeah like no joke a $7,000 bird Holland
that's just that you rich and you you
want to feel something you know you buy
that to give yourself filling you let
give yourself up yeah like making it
rain but with birds I don't want this
anymore
that's what I hunt and when I never go
to the strip club I'm not gonna throw
ones I'm just like you could had his
parrot
$650 right here this off market Paris
Russell Simmons bought one from the
store
yeah that's summer too and then his
assistant would come in for for food all
the time
hatching so how'd you end up working at
a parrot store it was like a friend of a
friend or you guys a cold application
Village Voice classified unit said if
you'll accept less than minimum wage
cash into the table to come shop it's it
that in the ad
now I feel I was suddenly odd but I
would like the Village Voice thing you
know my circle addition have you also
sampled a parrot before us many other
birds yeah all right not because you're
bad experience with parents you like nod
can't work for a while I was the ones
with the
cockatiels they've liked the thing I
gave the battery huh are the worst
guys but you know that sampling of kept
Paris has become kind of a real issue in
legalese because this this guy was
murdered in Los Angeles by his ex-wife
and the parrot was witness and this
parrot
apparently like talks so intelligently
that and was so traumatized by
witnessing this murder that the parrot
could actually recount all the incidents
that happened in the murder and the
parrot was brought into the courtroom
what is it
I had a pair of testifying weather was
accepted as real tomodea but I was
questioned by the DEF CON is fascinated
right and they played they played the
recording of the parent talking of the
murders on on radio and you know that's
how I heard about it and it was holy
[ __ ] no you know turns freak me out a
little bit cuz one of my one of my
homies he he has a piece of fairness and
his parents this person live forever
they live would be like well like fifty
years old sitting down or I wanna fill
alive merely 99 years so this thing
replayed at night you just hear children
playing and it was from their past like
you could be like remembered how their
voice was on the other kids but it's
like freaky because you hear in the
middle of the night just like we're like
kids running around but it was the
parrot that's creepy man I believe
they they can get it like really
precisely like they can do at the other
accents and yeah yeah yeah thank you
think this yeah yeah like to turn this
talk is taken nobody thought this when
they put this a bit on their bow gap I
have a clock I bet they talk about pairs
fifty men I bet they will do you have a
songs of you guys that uh with somebody
comes up to you like man that song you
you saying this anyway I was a saying
that at all pretty much every song every
time every song so what uh definitely
happens yeah earlier so usually pretty
obscures yeah they've gotten a little
bit more obvious lately I think but uh
but definitely in the past and I think
we like to leave it kind of open to
interpretation so you can kind of
experience your own scent here band is
famous for even comprehensible lyrics oh
yeah
we were on Conan one time and like the
subtitles said something backwards I'll
be a woman a woman say I really I really
like that a long name Bobby Ben it can
occur Conda yeah they thought he'd been
[ __ ] at one point he was like a
backwards local effect and like our
manager got taken up to the office of
Conan's producer and he had to sign some
piece of paper that it's no he did not
say I did go there that's weeping like a
hot McGee you have to go to the
principal's office that you think [ __ ]
yeah bleeping laws they're a bunch of
rigid more rigid in the US than they are
in Canada like anytime there's a you
know an expletive in you know as you
know you only hear on the radio or TV is
always believed oh right but we don't do
that Canada it's just let it all hang
out yeah I agree I think this is just
like in the commercials really passe
like bleeping you know some of these
words even like ads can you say like
this is [ __ ] good murder
tonight have you heard ads like that I
don't know I'm asking you and neither
vice has got it you know I mean I don't
know where the line is exactly but ya
know I got you Canada's too right we all
know that Wesley I played in Canada huh
have you played in Canada you know we
playing care of a bunch right we're in
Montreal all of the ones we all right
yeah none of the good cities and
companies in Canada Montreal Michael
we're trying to Ron so when we were
crossing the borders oh uh you know it's
got big deal crossing the border now you
probably know that it's you know not
what it used to be yes like though it
took us an hour to get through at
Buffalo the other day when we came down
me and my me and my partner and we were
sitting there and finally two guys said
oh you're a performer and suddenly you
know it was they were going to let us go
and the guy they started kidding us
about our money his son he said okay so
that's six bucks over six dollars I
guess he said and I said take Canadian
money and they he just like broke out
laughing right you that's not worth
anything
yeah that is dentistry or dollars
reevaluated so since you're presidential
election well I have the opposite
experience go on to Canada say you a
performer
step over here I got the opportunity how
many pieces do you have and what is this
to happen in 2007 yeah what how did she
even find us about that
now yeah going to Canada's toughie they
like what you're trying to get away from
that Trump [ __ ] not today
they over there deal with it
well you guys take on a have a sex to
your music yeah
who are you directing that question to
this to the poor to the house yeah these
people you mean no yeah you are you ever
done it never done it
not even unreleased tracks and
conversions that if it bears intrumental
it ok if isn't that if you didn't put it
out you like this is just for us you say
instrumentals for you I mean I was
kidding
oh if I have we don't really have any
instrumentals atenism yeah
John Coltrane works really well yeah but
that's another that's not to your own
music stick you know you're there
what about to each other's music plays I
guess it just makes me so self-conscious
yeah so did you alright well is the
thing too low because if you if you have
a bad run that time as you can you like
but this song is pretty dope I made this
like a distracting look this is mine
alright pull the smoke bomb yeah it can
happen how you ever see uh
your Spotify number thing like well this
is terrible we don't know no I don't
spot if I like two months ago yeah and I
haven't searched Animal Collective yet
no I mean that the number of plays were
you like oh this is how much you pay me
this is terrible I know if we don't get
shown that stuff you don't get shown as
though really when you direct the pilot
but that such I mean when I was able
tells us that kind of stuff it's like
you still owe us money
Oh music business rough I have a
question that when I was listening to
your music earlier I was a airing a
bunch of stuff from like oh man I would
sample this [ __ ] out of that that sounds
really hot you know I like to make well
that's the thing do you have you see
residuals from that and then we've got a
place we certain license kills yeah and
whose hands they have made a lot of
money afterwards from your license deals
but yeah you know did I think artists
and labels and other publishers are
willing to pay license fees - yeah you
know off top anyone that's sampled your
stuff in voluntary members he put me on
the spot here the daddy I think that'd
be hilarious
we probably a little Uzi song probably
done six weekend Isis deals with
recording artists for four samples for
the pop yeah mostly mostly mostly
hip-hop but not entirely right yeah film
is good right that the films will often
we just did a deal with therefore you
know French film company you know that
listen so it's okay you know
quien so it depends on the profile here
the music has in the film yeah right so
yeah I was just talking more about like
the sampling like you guys sample a lot
too right what do you guys sample other
people's music and little bit in so then
when you clear that is that like is that
a shitty process or isn't is a prime
yeah can be officially really suck that
the person is dead and you're dealing
with their estate
[Applause]
yeah it's not they catch you after the
fact that you didn't clear it that
really sucks oh [ __ ] so when you guys
first started like you get into any
legal issues with that
never had any serious no no which we
tried to quote Stevie Wonder once in one
of our songs not even sample I'm just I
sang some of his lyrics someone hit
songs and way to get it cleared because
we recorded it and it didn't even make
it to Stevie I don't think it just got
to his manager he was like I don't get
this nah you can't do it yeah what was
the well was the lyric it was from I
just called to say I love you so it's
just the chorus of i just called to say
I love you I just called to say I love
you yes said that into and white baby
like nope those words no you can't use
the room that in that order bro not
those words and that in that order you
better say to love to say I taught you I
pick up the phone I just call to say I
like you that actually was the lyric I
just fold that's what he said I'm not
even going to waste TVs time with this
and that was it I don't know it's like
we this might not be part of the story I
feel like a golf course was somehow
involved in the story but that might
have been us being like I bet the sucker
was just like on is like at the golf
course I got a cell phone but oh you may
be actually like did take the call on
the golf course but I don't think that
oh no that's true his here's what I you
all grew up in the the be MGH not to
beat you remember the 10 CDs first well
CDs for painting yeah you did that when
you never did it never did I have a
friend that did it I remember you didn't
do it I never know you none of you guys
did it just always went to records to
just what the Rick's yeah I think my
wife did it that she talked about having
one of those subscriptions come yeah I
got a lot of my first few albums on
there like right quantum only bill foot
but she will ago with some of those
early types that you did you get the
first few tapes weird Allen 3d yeah oh
yeah I got a weird out
live last year was one of the best shows
I've seen in a long yeah
weird al' in 3d I didn't see him in 3d
no I mean I was the night love it yeah
what's up gotta Helen through what uh
what songs would he take on on that one
I remember liking king of suede which
was king of pain okay
rider the Kaiser might have been on that
one right
oh I had a tire get a tiger
Rai of the Kaiser yeah that's weird as
him nature shredder hello you told my
bread bread yeah yeah the guy that owns
a deli okay he's like juicer music yeah
yeah that's cool tonight
I think eat it was on that one actually
oh yeah yeah that's ahead it eat it was
on dare to be stupid man I'll defer I'll
defer would you guys feel honored is
weird out did a totally around it so
items right now you know it's a seen him
recently which song do you think that
which song do you think he would do well
when I draw blank on any of our songs
with them I'd say my girls would be the
one like my hurls some like what gets
fried curls Frank rules there's a risk
though because I was heard that the
Chili Peppers are really pissed about
the yabba-dabba-doo now there were like
he has so many good songs and he wrote
like it's dumb Flintstones thing for us
like why did we get the lame Weird Al
song you never want to like risk it and
be the lame weird outside what all right
does he pay for right so is there any
but it's covered by parity law or any
law a lot you know that's kind of some
[ __ ] that was a case that was
started by the Luka yes it was Luke Luke
and song I was a he was making he did a
song where he was reciting some country
singer and I was like it was a big case
and that's the one that like changed to
parody look was that [ __ ] damn
she's like finally he got the case file
numbers yes oh yeah that's gonna work
yeah who lawyer came the one the ample
versus who okay and so yeah she had
great diction no crazy yeah
and so he he said a country lyrica that
yeah you yeah he parried it the country
lyric and then they try to sue him and
then the parity law came came about a
weird al was any without like I could do
whole track mean all I'm getting rich he
found the niche he filled that [ __ ]
mmm-hmm p.m. he did his thing and and
they lived his life and I'm proud of
where doubt can't hang on we're now I'm
proud of I just uh
because I'm does he have kids I don't
know number move dad jokes are probably
like all come on another word weird as
kids are probably so over it
yeah I still think it's worthwhile to
check in every once in a while like
because I gotta pay that much attention
to pop music our number one singles but
he's like done them for like 20 years
dude I've paid attention so like it's
not a bad way to spend an afternoon on
YouTube just be like what was he doing
in like 909 and you hear him do like the
Backstreet Boys I want it that way so I
bought it on eBay
super funny I want it that way hi buddy
booze extra syllable give it a Miley
Cyrus one recently Arianna CIA it's
pretty good he played that at the show
it was really good
parity long have you guys been partaking
in any of the moment stuff like the our
bus broke down today so we got here
there later you're kind of late also you
haven't punching anything a little late
sound [ __ ] oh so y'all just broken bus
got here and then a weird up and down
interview they had a thing he did the
workshop today
he built the synthesizer and they were I
didn't but did you pass the test it you
know what it was a long line to get
yours tested and I need to I needed to
go prep for this I'm not bad at
soldering I'm not good at soldering yeah
it was interesting doing I was making
this synthesizer and it was a it was but
doing the soldering and out of work was
kind of it was kind of therapeutic and
relaxing but you know they is really
hard yeah
this is really hard I was like oh wait
says I don't want to build one just just
give me one cousin I said I went out
just because they were because they had
all these synthesizers outside of that
of the shop and those I was playing
around I bought one of those I was it
called the UH it was like a wit it's
like a little one with the wood buttons
with the little round wood buttons you
get it sorry
yeah that's the one that thing is
awesome but one of them good stuff it's
a sampler right it's like guys real
subject here there's two little boxes
here that you usually the ones I give
the loopers like to the looper boxes all
right if Animal Collective uses it that
means I bought the right [ __ ] it looks
the design looks super cool two edges
really like I bought the little video
thing - did you check out the ID in it
yeah chat before but I've never and
they're super cool
yeah well really Internet what is this
synthesizer sitting here for it to fill
the offer hot sort of invites to
something doesn't it the game for zombie
just like to look at it every night it's
the red one I think initially yes it's
the visuals and just the you know
selling seller synthesized yes is there
you know we have winter we had a Moute
prodigy when we were in high school we
our friend got it from from his - junior
high they just happen to have one there
and you if you could have it so we we
inherited it from her Amanda just up in
my house so what are you going to do
with it you know
this is like this is like a collector's
weight of now this kind of smoked
Protestant we thought Halen using on
stage decided we want to want to but we
didn't even know what it was but then he
was like our friend was at the Chevy
it's like I've seen that thing in the
closet at my old school so seriously
though I mean with your recordings
I'm fascinated personally as a recording
artist of sorts
I'm fascinated with how you actually
achieve a lot of the sounds that you did
she do either unusual as me you know for
one of a better word I mean I think
they're very interesting sounds honestly
it's not a big secret I mean we just we
tweak things until they sound a little
bit unrecognized
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean it does it
take hours and hours and days and days
and days or is it happen really quick
curve and sometimes you just look out -
and he finds he's - things are a little
bit of a sample that's it you know it's
one thing when you you know watch it on
a movie or something like that but when
you just listen but it's a it's an
incredibly overall sound is like it's
amazing everything just kind of like you
know like makes this different kind of
vibe you might hear most other recording
artists do is especially like pop I mean
I I think I would excuse me I you know
correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
like it's pop music to me right and I
mean which probably accounts for your
you know the fact that you so many
people like here like it you know but
but it's more like pop music than you
know it's like not weird experimental or
anything like that but I mean really I
can't imagine how you get a lot of a lot
of those sounds or sounds I haven't
heard before you know and the way the
vocals blend together and all of it you
know this is really cool and yeah and it
seems to me you've got like a special
take on
on how you go into the studio to make
that happen
yeah I mean mr. Emily's leaves a lot
like there's a thing on the back of this
I don't know where it is says external
in we have like a bigger yard breath
right I recognize that yeah so in high
school like when we had one of these
things like that's the same friend
actually we found the mood like he he
figured out you could just plug
something into it and use this looks
like an effects box basically like you
know there ya know sounds very good what
do you what do you guys use happy with
it
besides vocals what do you guys usually
run do you run your drums through there
too like what do you guys use on drums
pianos so basically everything yeah
because I mean up here you just keep
your hand on it and kind of you know
sure do this and it's like a nun
programmable thing you sort of like ride
the wave of the song and that's a
question I'll ask you guys like I see
that especially with the music
everything is so like especially with
the way your vocals bounce off each
other and all the instruments are
running when you guys do that library
you just all like clocked in on the MIDI
clock or never like sync each other's
I'm stuff bad luck
well the other you send a click to the
drummer to the drummer yeah but over all
of our older stuff it's all just I mean
there'll be like a you know a drum
machine going or a drum track but then
everybody else has to just sort of like
keep time like more natural it was like
1 BPM that's live and everyone just kind
of follows in it I could have done it
that way oh wow play you know Kizer
guitar along with it or something like
that it's how public enemy did it
apparently we were told we're just
trying to like rude like you played the
beats live and you trigger the samples
live by hand as opposed to like
everything being sequenced with with
trigger oh yeah yeah yeah that's not why
we did it we're just kind of totally
like you guys's music like that that's
like maybe sample-based music that's not
yeah
so there's also mechanical Rhea yeah
give like freedom JD usually right
as that vibe it's like yeah I'll clock
dannion quantized it's just playing the
sample is good and you guys you guys
loop a lot too so that kind of just does
its own timing as well right yeah but
the loops can like get away from each
other so like sometimes you have to need
to do this like really fast like
restarts kind of a saying and hold thank
you pull back this is in order that goes
wrong you'll really wrong yeah that's
good sometimes sometimes yeah that's
what I keep telling me the rest of the
band it's okay if they make the next one
better
yes exactly oh no okay we use in ear
monitors too now that makes the mistake
kind of shows happen a little bit less a
little bit less yeah sometimes the
environment can just create crazy things
like slap reverb or something like that
when you're like playing a bunch of
buildings across the field and you get
like a slap delay so this is like an
extra delay you've added everything Lisa
played shows where it's just like the
rhythm of way slower and slower
keeping something completely different
than with the rhythm of the song and yes
and we're just like it's a different
song let's just go with it Julie here we
are - and luckily we haven't had the
Radiohead thing yet we're like the
entire PA cuts out but our in ears are
still going and so we keep playing
happily not knowing anything is we're
always that just happened to coach Owen
right and I've seen it happen - of other
times - I mean it's a danger so they use
those vineyards you know last year was
like has it yeah what about that time in
Brazil Chris came into the monitor was
like guys keep playing oh yeah oh yeah
well he told us to keep playing yeah oh
where you use your music without but we
didn't have yeah so you think we're
killing it but nobody's responding
murder this is called okay they don't
feel bad
that's exactly wrong with named Brazil
when I was talking about as a like we
had a feedback issue so we had to stop
and then the festival freaked out that
we were taking too long to figure out
the feedback so they started queuing up
house music which was Metallica the
attention of Nikki a while we were
playing and so then but then we got it
like we we fixed it quickly so we're
like let's go we started playing but it
was like when we started playing was
right when they had told like somebody
at the front house like get some
Metallica going to kill the cover the
funny ghost started at the same time and
as we are playing all the sudden like
the Black Album like Enter Sandman or
something just came through the monitors
he went on till they're 20 seconds
before we just started laughing and
we're like maybe that we give up
speaking of things going wrong John
maybe experiences a lot but it's hard to
travel with analog synthesizers at least
the older ones so panicked or with a
role in June of 60 all the time and if
it breaks it's just kind of like you're
here on the creek yeah
the we-well I don't know but I hope
everything goes together tomorrow for us
really well right we haven't had any
problems though but I think that I mean
you need to have a dedicated person
looking after your here which it I don't
have like weird we're doing it because
the older one I have to keep two and two
right we don't have yeah we had to show
the Hollywood Bowl one time it was like
our like the biggest show you had some I
don't know if we're supposed to like rip
on you get move faster mode but uh oh
a little little fatty that they yeah
look is really hard to keep in tune I
mean I was in rich areas outside of the
Hollywood Bowl it was just like we're
looking for like space blankets or
anything to cover it because there was a
you could not keep them in tune from
song to song and it was stressful I
stopped using it I know that happens you
can older ones I thought to do ones
because they generally are good that one
for some reason if a hey is like an old
one music right something that makes it
music whatever or a source sound guard
or whatever what you know I don't know
what that is and that that's interesting
I mean that is interest have you guys
order your work today actually is really
ordered I think it's good like this guys
order order order
yeah it's like it's very it's very
coherent alright the you know lyrically
is coherent because the sounds of the
that you make are the way they're
layered on top of each other and the way
they relate to each other and so forth
it's not it's not like chaotic it looks
weird because it's both you guys have
like a good happy medium they're like I
think it offends way in all world
yeah like how old we were what we were
interested at the time you know and I
mean when we play live - like we do that
the songs but we we like to not stop you
know like to keep the music going so we
try and improve like we don't really
figure out when we make our set how
we're going to get from one song to the
next song well a quick discussion before
we go on stage of like who has to change
memory cards or something like who
cannot participate in this transition
right like that's as far as we go that's
it really
those can get kind of chaotic here and
not they don't always go well so the
whole set just play we slept like once
or later don't like it you don't like
clapping
Oh life natto clap for us rock you gonna
play all the way throw give you these is
just have them like drums going in
between whatnot oh no three it was the
three of us really first started playing
kind of Live Together way to DX 27 yeah
and that's the best thing about it
really was you could just go into the
internal you know workings of it just
get it to sound insane like totally
crazy just balls yeah yeah
feedback icky frequency kind of thing
but it everything anything melodic he
could just made the craziest sound stuff
so you guys got you guys ever get into
the circuit bending stuff tone not we
don't do it ourselves I feel like people
will give you yeah people make so you
probably get some cool custom Kenny I
mean I feel like I've been given too
much Indian the first time I ever saw it
actually was the band wolf I hear
staying at their house on tour and they
had like changed one of those fish that
you put on the wall you know that like
yeah yeah I saw something like that on
YouTube you and that this is not me
other side maybe that so what uh what
time did you said tomorrow it would be a
thick four o'clock six o'clock six
o'clock so miles or negotiate see
everybody exact out John tomorrow six
o'clock and will practice at night
because I was like that one yeah ten
points
ha
thanks a lot and the collective sound
feels great Tom will topple I've learned
a lot about a music and uh how to be a
better interview very fine enjoy the
rest of the festival thank you very much
[Music]
that's been that episode that was a fun
one all right check us out send an email
the handsome Rambler gmail.com send
money if you want what something some
podcast they get money from their fans
said money sometimes people send money
people have the patreon or whatever up
on the or they paid for helping people
just donate to the podcast I mean we
have sponsors and with but I mean if
people want to just straight up send
money way to pay your own price button
we should put it on our website
yeah you know what someone [ __ ] - just
keep ving warned me asking me for money
that I never met really get it kind of I
think it's his own kind of running joke
and you get my email address and he'll
say oh I need this money
but it's bet we made it was a fully but
I don't other donors like instead of
that it's the internet well you know
people gotta make better use at a time
yeah anyways thanks for listening
goodnight well afternoon morning yay
whatever thank you later
[Music]
[Music]